should I go check it out
[Music]
shit man Oh can you get that light out
of my eyes things doing in my closet
okay don't go question why I'm setting
an error okay this is my alone time and
on your way out can you shut the door a
little bit of privacy would be nice
insidious chapter 2 is directed by James
Wan and stars Patrick Wilson Rose Byrne
and Barbara Hershey now before I explain
the plot of this movie I have to warn
you that I kind of have to spoil certain
elements of the way the first film ended
because this film picks up basically
directly after the first one concluded
and so to talk to you about this movie I
kind of have to reveal certain elements
of the way the first film ended so if
you don't want to know that you have
been warned
so if we saw the first film you know
that Patrick Wilson's character took
something back with him from the further
and this thing is inside of him and
wants to use him to harm his family the
creepy stuff is happening at night again
their son Dalton's hearing noises again
and they have to try to solve a mystery
from the past to be able to fix wrongs
in the present for James Wan to make a
film like the conjuring which was a big
hit critics liked it people liked it
made a lot of money for a low-budget
film just like the insidious if James
Wan is capable of making two good horror
films in the same year this close a time
span he is definitely a great talent let
me tell you something he is a great
talent insidious chapter 2 is a creepy
and pretty fun horror film that I had a
good time watching that had great
performances terrific stylistic imagery
really good use of sound and set pieces
and props and makeup and although the
story got a little goofy from time to
time the actors really helped ground it
in reality because the actors gave such
good performances in this movie it was
very similar to the conjuring in that
way where the story gets a little bit
over-the-top and kind of goofy at times
but because the actors are giving such
grounded performances and doing such a
good job to sell this goofiness you
really start to get into it and it's a
credit to these actors especially
Patrick Wilson in this movie who I think
gives a terrific performance as this guy
he wants to protect his family because
part of him is still him but the other
part doesn't wanted to do that his
performance in this movie was definitely
to me anyway channeling a little bit of
Jack Nicholson in the shining he had
that sort of big smile to him at times
but very menacing and I thought he did a
terrific job in the movie I'm not saying
that the shining is in any way yet the
shining is better yeah that's that the
shining is much better but this movie is
still a pretty fun horror film and yes
like I said it does get kind of goofy at
times the script kind of wants you to
get into certain scenes and you're like
this is just really over the top and I
recognize that but I think it might
actually add some
to the movie and in all honesty because
like there are certain horror films that
you want to be really serious you want
to sit there and not have anything take
you out of it but insidious chapter 2 is
the kind of movie where I do feel like
they can get a little bit goofy because
obviously anyone who sits down and
actually thinks about the movies like
yeah this is absurd this is just crazy
but I really like the way they handled
the more goofy aspects of the movie and
I think that they did a pretty good job
with it just like with the conjuring
James Wan is very good at that
low-budget retro old-school type of
horror real sets real props real imagery
really good sound effects it's sort of
his like that old TV show are you afraid
of the dark when I was a kid I would
watch that intro and it terrified me
with the swings and the fan and the
creepy attic door and the music and the
match that show just had like these real
sets from this creepy stuff with knit I
know it's not scary at all anymore but
when I was a kid I thought it was the
greatest thing ever the intro still
scares me though it's very suspenseful
I'm sorry but James Wan did a really
good job creating legitimate scares in
this movie there were moments in the
movie where I did get goosebumps and
things actually affected me that I
thought wow that's pretty creepy and
it's not just loud jump scares every two
seconds because I don't find that scary
it's just your theater has terrific
surround sound so you are startled by a
loud noise that's not scary that's just
there are there's a boom and now you're
afraid there were images in this movie
there were moments where I was like yeah
that's that's bother something like that
is creepy and pretty good for a pg-13
movie - I don't really view the rating
scale anymore as an accurate depiction
of will this be scary or not just
because movie has extra f Wars and some
blood and some boobs it doesn't mean
it's gonna be scary at all
cuz that's not scary to me a genuine
suspense is scary and insidious chapter
two definitely had that also let me
remind you that as I judged this film
there are certain elements I'm looking
at for one James Wan directed to horror
films this year and I gotta imagine
that's pretty difficult to do the fact
that either of them were remotely good
is very impressive because that's a lot
of people breathing down your neck and
the other thing I was looking at is that
this is a horror sequel
I mean those almost always suck huge-ass
and this movie impressed me I thought
the actors especially Rose Byrne and
Patrick Wilson did a really good job to
ground these people in reality while all
these strange unrealistic things were
happening and while the script does get
a little goofy at times I really really
like the way this film connects to the
first film I won't explain it or spoil
it or anything but there are definitely
certain elements in the film where you
could see certain things connecting and
you're like oh okay that makes sense now
and there's also a huge mystery element
to the film where characters have to
investigate something that happened in
the past to be able to learn more about
the present I really got into that
because I like mysteries in movies and I
gotta say this movie really kind of
surprised me actually I was kind of
expecting it to not be good but I had a
lot of fun that despite its goofy
elements and a few contrived parts where
there were certain things where you're
like okay that just didn't feel like it
flowed correctly I'm gonna give
insidious chapter 2 a B I think that
it's a fun horror film and if you liked
the first one you'll probably have a
good time with this one I think if you
watch them both back-to-back that'll
definitely help because this film just
cuts right to the chase there's not much
build-up I had a good time with this
movie let me know you guys think when
you do see it thanks very much for
watching guys and as always if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck my nice
[Music]